sit by myself
talking to them
like mother like son that's sierra and
her one-year-old son wynn wilson showing
off their new matching cars
yup the two are sitting side by side in
similar bronco suvs of course the
singer's got the real deal while her
little one has the mini version for kids
the singer simply captions the video how
we roll giving all credit to wynn's
daddy her husband russell wilson for
filming the sweet moment it's just about
you know spending quality time with each
other and when wynn isn't busy cruising
down the driveway he's hitting lots of
exciting milestones like taking his
first steps
[Music]
[Applause]
yup cheering went on with his proud
parents is his older sister sienna
turns out it's a moment that meant a lot
to the seattle seahawks quarterback
because it happened on the field where
he practices every day i just like win
is like a super baby like he's like
super whim as for sienna she's a little
star of her own
that's my best friend
the four-year-old definitely shines like
her mama on tick-tock come on just check
out her dance moves
[Music]
is the cutest thing in the world
and she got so much personality the
thing is she was dancing and she was
dancing a level up today right and so
she's grooving she's grooving she's
grooving and i'm like man she's got
better
she's got better rhythm than me she's
won
and we got to give props to sierra's
other son future whom she shares with
her ex of the same name little future
well he's making headlines of his own
yeah we fancy like applebee's on a date
night
so you stay with your oreos
yeah the seven-year-old also joins his
mom on tock but we're talking about
this recent moment that was rather
presidential sierra brought all three of
her little ones to the white house in
november to help promote the covet 19
vaccine for kids and get this during
their trip future exchanged some words
with president joe biden before he
walked off he came to say hi to us and
as you see there you know future goes
the first thing he says to the president
goes i'm vaccinated and the president
yells back i'm vaccinated too
so that was really cute and really sweet
and when she's not busy performing or
being a mama sierra is making a
difference last year the one-two step
singer and her hubby launched a charter
through their why not you foundation a
non-profit dedicated to education
children's health and fighting poverty
it's clear sierra is one passionate
activist what i'm really proud of is
that a lot of the like big visions and
dreams that i had in this case both russ
and i have shared are happening
there's just no greater feeling than
experiencing that and russ we always
talk about like the blessing and
gift of being able to do life together
and just how special that is but also
being able to impact together
it's just it's it's incredible it's an
incredible feeling
and
you know it's just been amazing to do
all these things together